Josephine warwini and bootsire both told
us their husbands were killed when the
M23 armed group attacked their villages
many people in this camp on the
outskirts of Goma tell similar stories
Josephine says she went back to her
Village last week and found her husband
dead among about 30 men who were killed
with machetes and left barely buried in
Shallow Graves
M23 killed him as we were running away
they caught us and separated the men
from the women many men were taken by
the M23 in the bush most of them were
killed and my husband was among them
Democratic Republic of Congo's Army says
it's fighting Rwandan soldiers under the
guise of M23
rwanda's widely understood to back the
armed group or they rwanded denies it
the Army has failed to stop m23's
advances and many people here question
why the government hasn't done more to
support its forces they defeated M23
this time 10 years ago but at the time
they had substantial International
military support and Rwanda was
sanctioned
this time an East African Regional force
is meant to help burundian soldiers are
the latest to arrive but it's not clear
if any of the countries contributing
troops
have the political will all the
resources to fight M23 or even Rwanda
here in Congo
General constant Dima is the third
Commander to take over Congo's military
operation in less than a year just as a
regional deadline for M23 to withdraw is
due to expire
our position in the buyer was attacked
earlier today this is why we have to
repeat that we still have multiple
violations of ceasefire
M23 blames Congo's forces for breaking
the ceasefires and denies committing
atrocities in spite of mounting evidence
there are growing reports of mass
killings and rapes from the hundreds of
thousands of new arrivals in the camps
ire says her husband was trying to
protect their herd of cattle last month
when M23 Fighters tried to forcibly
recruit him and killed him when he
refused
she says we need help we're suffering
and we can't go back to our farm
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera Gomer Democratic
Republic of Congo